oh no my girl I got no cake this is real
my girl I got into a big fight like two
weeks ago because I finally caught on
our game here's what I realized women
never apologize even if they're wrong
they'll apologize but they'll never say
I'm sorry what they'll do is they'll
like nuzzle up to you like walk like
come to you like real cute and quiet and
then nuzzle up to your shoulder and then
just look up at you these puppy-dog eyes
and this cute and as do you love her
you're just like how do you worry my
[ __ ] girl Judith girl stop it and I
realized there's no real apology but my
girl yelled at me for no reason
fake apology then yelled at me again
then trying to another fake apology and
then I was like all I see was she doing
so I didn't I didn't I didn't get mad
but I was I was a nun I was nice enough
set I finally got himself like not you
know they could do that [ __ ] you already
to beat you and think I forgive you no
matter what you do he got talk to me
with respect it's a relationship all
right treat me better
she was so flustered that I called out
her game she just went into the bedroom
and locked it and that's the setup
fellas you feel disrespected get locked
out of here on bedroom she's trying to
provoke you to go here so she could win
the argument but you lost right there
I'm on to that game I'm not gonna knock
like a [ __ ] like B please let me in
let's talk about it John made me sleep
on the couch this time I'd have looked
at that couch like don't threaten me
with a good time
we might gonna bum your mom is my house
I get a great night of sleep on this
couch
this capital throw his [ __ ] leg on
top of me all night trap me like a
Chilean miner love this couch girl c'mon
you objectively on like what what did
you think I'm gonna be like oh my god oh
babe what am I gonna do with all this
free time what am I gonna do watch the
TV show I want to watch am I gonna focus
on my career
please no so no the best [ __ ] ever a
black man or go ahead girl we'll be fine
cuz you gotta know you guys in five
years deep you love each other you're
gonna be alright
have your fight is fine one month that's
my advice to you fights a no big deal if
y'all care about each other never don't
matter let her get mad don't give a [ __ ]
you can't try to fix it there's no
fixing it it's just not just let him be
mad it's like I don't even know you know
here - I have I have dog and you just
gotta let him run around he's gotta let
him be man just let it all out anything
tired and go to sleep
women get upset man they get upset like
men get hungry your ass he doing feet
hungry yeah he not gonna say no what
does a guy always say that's women and
upset you ever asked you come babe
aren't you upset I couldn't be
let's just keep walking around for a bit
I'll work up a temper